they call themselves musicians a band of
Russian mercenaries from the Wagner
group paid to fight where the Kremlin
needs them their founder and conductor
were evgeny pagojin and Dimitri utkin
both killed in a Russian plane crash
this week pregogin had fallen out with
Putin after his men led a mutiny in June
mercenaries are banned under Russian law
but Russian President Vladimir Putin
admitted to paying billions of dollars
to the Wagner
I want to note and I want us all to know
about this too the maintenance of the
entire Wagner group was fully provided
by the state from the budget of the
ministry of Defense from the state's
budget we fully funded this group
whoever was responsible for pregojin's
death the Kremlin is moving to take full
control of his Global Empire set up 10
years ago to help Russian forces in
Ukraine the Wagner group has expanded to
almost every continent from Venezuela to
Syria and Africa an estimated 5 000
Wagner mercenaries are in Africa
fighting armed groups for a monthly fee
along with access to minerals and
natural resources
experts believe revenues from logging
alone to be close to a billion dollars
Russian mercenaries controlled the
endessima gold mine in the Central
African Republic worth 2.7 billion
dollars from bangi Wagner runs a beer
and vodka making company called Africa
tellur and there are troll farms for
hire that have fueled anti-french
sentiment online in former French
colonies in Africa and meddling in
elections in the United States
the Wagner group produces films
portraying Russians as benevolent Heroes
this was the last video of pregogin
supposedly filmed in Northern Mali one
day before his death he says Wagner is
here to make Russia even greater and
Africa even more free pregosian sucks up
a lot of attention but I also think what
Wagner does this PMC is bigger than just
one person
it's bigger than pagosan or any one or
two Executives and I think um
yeah I suspect we will see someone come
in to take his spot perhaps someone less
flashy less controversial
um more aligned and more loyal to Putin
the Wagner group is a symphony of
companies with the musicians playing a
key role the Kremlin cannot do without
Nicholas honk Al Jazeera